et pour en parler nous sommes avec
anastasia carabasse guide conférencier
au mémorial de la shoah à hauteur de la
shoah l'obsession de l'antisémitisme
depuis le 19e siècle aux éditions bréal
bonsoir anastasio carabasse merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france vous
avez assisté je croise ces cérémonies
aujourd'hui avec emmanuel macron qu'est
ce que voudront retiendrez écoutez
c'était très émouvant de voir toutes ces
personnalités qui sont venus au mémorial
c'est un site symbolique qui a un rôle
fondamental aujourd'hui pour notamment
les nouvelles générations pour les
citoyens de demain votre le présent dans
république bien sûr un discours poignant
mais également des députés la maire de
paris et toutes les personnes qui
travaillent mémoire de la shoah au
quotidien c'était important qu'on se
rassemble tous avec notamment les
rescapés ceux qui restent et
malheureusement il ne reste plus
beaucoup de monde et c'est important de
les porter de leur montrer que nous
avons une mission on en parlera
justement après de ce devoir de mémoire
c'est une commémoration 75e anniversaire
qui a lieu moment on apprend
l'augmentation de 130 % du nombre de
faits racistes et xénophobes en 2019 des
chiffres alarmants concernant également
le caractère antisémite un précisément
puisque beaucoup de juifs tout
simplement ne se sentent pas en sécurité
en france on apprend que voilà ils ont
augmenté de 27% par rapport à 2018 ces
faits antisémites on se dit dans ces
moments là que l'histoire ne sert pas
toujours de leçon quand l'histoire est
bien enseigner je pense qu'elle peut
être un rempart contre l'antisémitisme
je suis également enseignant
d'histoire-géographie
j'ai des lycéens en face de moi tous les
jours et je sais l'importance de
l'enseignement peut-être qu'en france
même si nous sommes considérés comme les
bons élèves de l'europe sur
l'enseignement de la shoah en france il
ya encore un travail à faire la chose
n'est pas une histoire figé c'est pas
quelque chose qui est fermé c'est
quelque chose qui en construction c'est
important aujourd'hui de dire que la
shoah
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
qui fait partie juste du passé on a des
enseignements à tirer
nous devons transmettre parce qu'on est
à l'abri de rien il ya en moyenne 800
actes antisémites par an en france pour
une communauté qui représente moins de
1% de la population et il ya un institut
britannique qui a fait un sondage en
décembre 2018 qui dit que 21 % des 18-34
ans n'ont jamais entendu parler de la
shoah
pourtant officiellement on enseigne
l'ajustement j'allais faire parler les
études et jeu sauf erreur de ma part
cette étude ifop de 2018 d'illogique un
français sur dix j'avais entendu parler
de la shoah et ça s'aggrave avec les
jeunes vous dit on et les bons élèves de
l'europe vous êtes vous mêmes profs
alors comment vous expliquez ça ça
paraît incroyable qu'un français sur dix
on n'est pas entendu parler écouter
l'éducation nationale en france fait
officiellement fait un vrai travail et
je sais que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est vraiment engagé le
président également après il faut voir
le quotidien des enseignants
il ya de très nombreux enseignants je
les ai vécus notamment dans des points
difficiles quand j'ai commencé ma
carrière
nous sommes seuls et donc on nous dit il
faut enseigner la shoah en troisième
officiellement on a quatre heures pour
enseigner la seconde guerre mondiale et
être heures 4 heures la seconde guerre
mondiale points et dans la seconde
guerre mondiale il ya éventuellement la
shoah c'est à dire de 10 minutes à une
heure maximum parce qu'on peut pas
dépasser sinon peut pas comprendre la
seconde guerre mondiale donc ça veut
dire quoi un élève qui finit son collège
il a pas vaguement entendu parler de la
choix dans certains établissements ont
fait un travail en profondeur mais pas
partout surtout dans des coins difficile
on sait que l'enseignement la shoah pose
problème au lycée c'est pareil au lycée
l'enseignement la shoah peut aller
jusqu'à un maximum deux heures les
enseignants sont pris par l'emploi du
temps et par les programmes donc
finalement le choix on l'évoquent certes
mais peut-être pas assez et peut-être
pas en profondeur et d'ailleurs dans les
nouveaux programmes c'est toujours le
cas la shoah fait partie d'un programme
d'un sujet parmi d'autres et vous parlez
surtout dans les coins difficile on le
sait c'est compliqué on le dit sur dans
la presse les plateaux de télé c'est
très compliqué d'enseigner la shoah dans
dans les banlieues notamment
est ce que pour vous il ya une forme de
résignation
finalement un petit de lâcheté on laisse
tomber pour ne pas heurter pour avoir
une forme de paix quel est votre regard
là-dessus je vais pas généraliser parce
que je connais beaucoup de collègues en
mémoire de la chanteuse nous accueillons
beaucoup d'enseignants d'ailleurs pour
les former parce qu'il faut former les
enseignants comment est ce qu'on
enseigne la joie c'est compliqué qu'est
ce que vous voulez dire aux élèves en
1h06 millions de personnes exterminées
pas tant que ça mais je parle justement
du ministère auquel est alors il quitte
là dessus
officiellement il ya un vrai travail
bien sûr bien sûr mais malheureusement
et on le voit dans les vingt dernières
années georges bensoussan a parlé des
territoires perdus de la république
malheureusement à un moment donné je
peux pas citer une personne mais un
système a fait qu'on a fermé les yeux et
qu'on a préféré acheter la paix sociale
en disant c'est compliqué d'ailleurs
regardez les programmes les programmes
de terminale premier chapitre d'histoire
nous enseignants on doit choisir entre
les mémoires de la seconde guerre
mondiale où les mémoire de la guerre
d'algérie
donc ça veut dire quoi oui vous ça veut
dire que dans certains établissements
parlera pas de mémoire la seconde guerre
mondiale parce que c'est plus facile de
parler des morts de la guerre d'algérie
donc c'est au professeur qui
qu'ils aient laissé si j'ose dire la gur
de responsabilité de choisir entre
renier la choix et la guerre d'algérie
c'est ça que vous mobile comme si comme
si la guerre finalement les comme si les
deux guerres étaient similaires on parle
d'une guerre d'extermination c'est
d'actualité avec emma exactement
justement ça sera l'objet de notre débat
à 21h30 qui a fait ce parallèle en ça
veut dire que c'est l'un ou l'autre
c'est assez étonnant ce que vous nous
dites oui il n'y a pas de débat là
dessus je veux dire historiquement
parlant on ne peut pas comparer que je
ne dis pas que la guerre d'algérie n'est
pas importante ça n'a rien à voir et on
parle d'une guerre d'extermination
contre une guerre de décolonisation ça
n'a pas du tout le même aux gens qu'il
faut choisir l'enseignement entre les
deux
voilà les enseignants à l'otan alors
qu'il faudrait peut-être au contraire
enseigner bien et deux oui pourquoi pas
les deux mais dans ces cas là on fait la
distinction et on ne demande pas aux
enseignants finalement de choisir
on ne peut pas choisir dans ces cas là
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs solutions
propose également le gouvernement la loi
via contre la haine de toute forme de
racisme la résolution maillard qui
touchait plus spécifiquement
l'antisémitisme qui estiment ils
l'antisionisme à de l'antisémitisme pour
vous c'est aussi des débuts de solutions
pour lutter contre l'antisémitisme où il
vaut mieux effectivement se cantonner à
l'éducation
je pense que tous ces éléments sont
importants pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
ils font un ensemble de choses et un
ensemble d'acteurs qui travaillent en
collaboration
c'est l'enseignement mais c'est aussi la
justice il faut un cadre bien sûr avec
des lois moi je sais avec mes élèves que
les réseaux sociaux jouent un rôle
extrêmement important aujourd'hui les
théories du complot c'est dans les
réseaux sociaux que ça marche la loi est
importante mais sans l'enseignement à
côté une une société ne peut pas
fonctionner sans un enseignement solide
et là dessus la france a encore du
travail à faire à mon sens vous parler
évidemment de l'enseignement et du
devoir de mémoire avec les derniers
rescapés
de la shoah est ce que vous connaissez
extrêmement bien ce sujet est ce que les
autorités ont prévu la suite justement
pour entretenir ce devoir de mémoire
nous sommes les témoins des témoins les
derniers sont en train de partir les
derniers rescapés et c'est important et
on l'a vu aujourd'hui c'est important de
leur montrer que nous n'allons pas
oublier ce qui s'est passé et que nous
allons transmettre toujours au quotidien
transmettre pourquoi j'ai pas parce que
c'est une obligation on transmet parce
que c'est une obligation je veux dire de
l'éducation nationale on transmet parce
que nous sommes des êtres humains il ya
encore 80 ans on envoyait des enfants
dans les chambres à gaz
quelle société voulons-nous pour demain
donc ces rescapés doivent comprendre que
nous sommes ici pour transmettre et pour
transmettre et que nous n'allons pas
oublier parce que si nous oublions on
risque de refaire les mêmes erreurs et
ça on ne le veut pas nous enseignants et
nous aussi
guide conférencier au moral de la chose
aujourd'hui et plus globalement ça sera
ma dernière question est ce que les
autorités le gouvernement était la
hauteur de la situation où on en parle
voilà quand il faut en parler puis on
balaye ça un petit peu après alors si
c'est juste pour faire des
collaborations c'est sûr que bon ça
c'est important on l'a vu aujourd'hui
mais une commémoration ne suffit pas
est-ce qu'il est à la hauteur je pense
que j'ai pas de réponse à vous donner
mais quoi qu'il en soit c'est important
les discours mais les actes
à mon sens sont encore plus importants
et dans l'éducation nationale
malheureusement ça fait dix ans que je
suis dans l'éducation nationale on a
entendu beaucoup de discours
c'est important qu'il y ait les actes
derrière donc on attend et on espère que
ça va changer
merci beaucoup anastasio carabasse
d'avoir été avec nous en direct assure
rt france